[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Palmer 1.0 is in the
house and today, I'm
going to introduce you to the
brand new Polymer Starter Kit.
So come on down and
let's get hacking.
So Polymer Starter Kit is
brand new opinionated scaffold
for building
Polymer apps, and it
is jam packed full of awesome.
Out of the box, it provides
a really nice layout
that leverages the latest
1.0 material design elements.
It also has support for theming
using custom properties,
and we showed these off
in the last episode.
Now you're seeing it
kind of at a bigger
scale, which is really cool.
The other really awesome
thing about the Starter Kit
is that it comes
with optional support
for offline first
development, which
means in your
application, you can go.
You could set it into Airplane
mode, refresh the browser,
and everything would still load.
You could even navigate
to different pages
within your application.
Things would still work.
What's doing this
magic behind the scenes
is a new technology
called Service Worker,
and I'm going to talk more
about that in a future episode
because it's just so cool.
So how do you get started?
Well, there's two approaches.
You could head over to the
Polymer Starter Kit home page
and download the zip bundle.
That is one way to do it.
Or, if you want to
be a hotshot like me,
you can install the
Polymer Yeoman Generator.
The generator pulls down the
latest version of the Starter
Kit so anytime you want to
just spin up a new project,
you just go to
your command line,
you type "yo polymer," and
boom, you're ready to rock.
Now, once you're set up,
bust open your editor
and this is what you should see.
The files in the
root of the project
are dedicated to things
like package management--
I've got a package JSON here--
linters with JSNRC and JSCSRC.
So all this is build type stuff.
Up here in the App
Directory, this
is actually where all of
the UI for my application
is going to live.
And because I downloaded
the version that
has support for the
Gulp build process,
I've also got a Gulp file here.
But if you went with the light
version which doesn't include
Gulp, that's totally fine.
You don't necessarily need
this for this tutorial,
but I just want you to
know that that's there.
So all of these files might
seem really overwhelming,
but don't panic.
There's tons of
great stuff in here
and I'm going to help
walk you through all of it
over the next few
episodes of Polycast.
For today, let's just
start really small.
We're going to preview
the app and then
we're going to update
some of the theme colors.
Now, because the Starter
Kit uses Gulp for its
build process, I'm going to
hop onto my terminal and type
out "gulp serve," which will
put boot a local server,
and it's even going to
open my browser for me,
which is pretty awesome.
Nice.
Now, if you're using
the light version
of the site which
doesn't include Gulp,
you can use your own server.
So here, I'm just booting
up Python simple HTTP server
on port 3,000.
And then I would need to go
and open my browser myself,
but this is an option
for the folks who
downloaded that version.
Next, I'm going to open
up my elements.html file
and I'm going to drop
in a paper FAB, which
is short for Floating
Action Button.
So I scroll down.
There's a lot of elements
that are imported already,
but just right underneath
the Paper toolbar here,
I'll drop in my own
import for Paper FAB.
So I can have a little bit of
UI showing up on the screen.
Next, I'm going to hop
over to my index.html file.
And in the section that
says "data route home,"
I'm going to take this
paragraph here and just delete
it and replace it with my
floating action button.
So get rid of this p-tag
and drop in that paper FAB
and give it an icon of Add.
Now when I save this and
go back to my browser,
that floating action
button is just
going to be there on screen
even though I haven't hit
Refresh or anything like that.
Now, the way that
this is working
is the Gulp version
of the Starter Kit
comes with a tool
called Browser Sync,
and Browser Sync synchronizes
updates to all of your devices
whenever you save
files in your editor.
So if I had a phone or a tablet
plugged into my laptop right
now, I was trying to
debug on all of them once,
they would all refresh
all at the same instant,
which is really cool.
Next, I'm going to open
up the apptheme.html file.
And if you watched
the previous episode,
this should look kind
of familiar to you.
Inside of this file, we've
got custom properties
for theming our
entire application.
So you see, I've got this
root pseudo class up here,
and then a few different
custom properties over there
on the right.
Now, I can use these.
These are basically the hooks
that all of the material design
elements in the application
have exposed to me
so that I can style
and theme them.
This root pseudo
class right here,
if you've never
seen one of those
before, that just targets the
highest parent in the page,
and it's a good place to provide
some values for our custom
properties.
Now, a way to do that
is to go over to a site
called Material Palette, and you
can actually just select colors
that you want to use.
These are all coming from the
material design color palette.
You can just click
on a few swatches.
So I'm going to pick
pink and light blue.
This is going to build
a palette for me.
And you can actually
see a preview up there
in the top right, and
then down below it,
there are some hex values.
So I can copy and paste those
hex values into my theme file.
And once I save this, I switch
back over to my browser.
And you can see that now
my header is updated,
the floating action
button is updated,
and even these little lighter
colors over here in my icons
have been updated.
So really cool.
Just with a tiny
bit of work, we've
already started theming
this application
and dropping new
elements into it.
So you've taken your first step
into the world of Polymer 1.0
and I hope you're
all really excited.
I'm going to keep digging
into the Starter Kit,
showing off some of the cool
features here on Polycast.
So be sure to click that
little Subscribe button.
Ask questions down in the
comments if you have them.
AS always, thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, guys.
What's up?
Rob.
The Q&A time.
Todd Judd writes in and
says, "In Polymer 0.5,
you had layout attributes that
came bundled with Polymer.
Those don't seem to be
around in Polymer 1.0,
so what happened to those?
Good question, Todd.
Around version
Polymer 0.8, 0.9, we
switched from using
attributes to classes.
And then in 1.0, we actually
took all of those classes
and we bundled them up
into their own element set
called Iron Flex Layout.
So you can actually follow
this link right here
and go to the repo
for Iron Flex Layout.
And inside that repo, we
have custom properties
that you can apply
to your own elements.
We also have CSS files in
there that you can just
import into your elements and
use those to get your Flexbox
layout attributes back, or
layout classes, I should say.
So again, Todd, great question.
Thanks for writing in.
We will send you some swag.
If you have questions
about Polymer,
leave them down in the comments.
If it's a juicy question,
we will try and feature you.
As always, thank you
so much for watching
and I'll see you next time.